[Music]
hi thanks everyone for coming I'd also
like to take a moment to thank the back
of the house they've been doing a
wonderful job with this conference and
round of applause for them
one more group to quickly thank as
you'll notice at the side over here
we've got live transcriptions happening
that's a person who's doing a great job
and trying to help make this event more
inclusive so a quick one for them as
well and I know this is the last session
before the concert you're all tired and
we're excited for the concert so uh well
well with that I'd like to first take a
moment to introduce my compete RIA Myles
Boren's he's a developer advocate on
Google cloud he's also a long-standing
member of the node.js community and in
fact the director of the node.js
technical steering committee fun fact
about him is the first time he used node
was for an art installation so he's also
an artist and a musician it's true um
here we have Noemi
Seifer Naomi's a senior software
engineer on service working on cloud run
how many of you all in the audience have
heard of cloud run before by the end of
this presentation we'll be all the hands
and I'm excited about that
Naomi is also working on the K native
client working group is the lead of that
team you'll hear a little bit more about
that project as well as we get into the
talk Naomi is a language polygon loves
every single language but not
necessarily all of them equally um
Naomi back to you so this talk is about
service what is even service it's a buzz
word that you may have been hearing it's
like hot in the cloud compute sphere
these days so our conception of it is
kind of a catch-all term it has a few
components that if a compute product
meets them we we consider it under the
umbrella term observer list the first of
those
is that you don't have to worry about
infrastructure management
you might hear me repeat this you don't
have to worry about phrase pretty often
you don't have to worry about his kind
of the thena
theme of serverless so first you don't
have to worry about infrastructure
management no VM provisioning no metal
provisioning no bare metal provisioning
your scaling is going to be automatic
and it will scale up and down as your
needs require another element of it is
that your security is fully managed you
don't have to worry about some kernel
vulnerability or or for a lot of the
products some library vulnerability
happening all of those are updated
behind the scenes so you don't have to
worry about it and you also don't have
to worry about paying for resources that
you're not using the products that we
consider serverless
you pay only for what you use you pay
only for the CPU and memory and requests
that you're using and when nobody is
using the service it scales down to zero
and you don't pay anything for that so
in this talk we'll talk you through the
three server lists compute options that
Google Cloud has cloud functions App
Engine and cloud run and when you might
want to use each of them because they
each have their strengths and weaknesses
these options lie along the spectrum of
server list which is part of kind of a
larger spectrum of computation where at
one end you have you just write a tiny
bit of code and you send it to a server
and it runs it for you like Google Cloud
functions and on the other end of that
you have requisitioning blade servers to
go put in your data center but we won't
talk about that because that's not
serverless
so we'll talk about the spectrum of
server list compute where at one end you
have more ease of use and at the other
end you have more control though they're
all with good control and good ease of
use so what will be we build so what we
ended up collaborating on is a URL link
shortening service it's built entirely
service lis
an architecture that will show you
momentarily but perhaps the first thing
that we should show you is the product
itself so I'm gonna come over here and
get on to the demo machine here and
we're gonna go to min ki dot s H small
knish and we could see the basic UI here
this has been built with material for
web we can click on the URL here and
let's make a short link for google.com
we'll submit that short link and get
this minified link almost right away so
we can see that it has a little sha here
that we've generated and it takes us to
google.com we could similarly go here
and create the short link and give it a
specific short link like goog submit and
wait and oh we got a 409 that the short
link already exists and goes somewhere
else and we got this really fun cow
that's giving us a little fortune as
part of our 404 page will similarly get
errors if we try to go for short links
that don't exist or if we try to go to
routes that don't exist with the
appropriate errors and get different
fortunes each time so now if we move
back to the presentation we can talk a
little bit more about the architecture
that we're working with so when you come
in you're going to be using a front-end
that's been built with Express and it's
run on Google App Engine
that's routing all of the requests that
are coming from the browser then
depending on the endpoint that you're
hitting
we're either creating a short link or
getting a short link and we're using a
cloud function to make calls to the
database there and for any of the errors
were actually hitting cloud run because
we got some server list bash going but
we'll show you that a bit later one of
the things that I really love about this
architecture is that we've managed to
sandbox the access to the database from
the front-end application through iam
roles we can even limit the access to
the database altogether so that it's
only the function service accounts that
can call it and we're also making sure
that we're sanitizing the data before it
ever gets to the database so there's no
way from that front-end
to directly access the database at all
now the first product that we want to
dig into a little bit more is cloud
functions not only would you like to
tell us a little bit more about it so
any cloud functions you write code to do
one thing you don't have to worry about
your request plumbing that's that's
handled by the cloud functions framework
for you and your dependencies are
resolved in the clouds you don't worry
about dependency management you don't
worry about request plumbing and you can
save your functions up to trigger by a
variety of things so you can set them up
to trigger by someone creating an object
in a storage bucket you can set them up
to trigger by someone publishing
something to a cloud pub/sub topic or by
HTTP request from the outside we or from
your cloud which is what we've done here
and you've got no worries about
concurrency you only have one thread of
execution in your cloud function at once
so it's really the easiest to use of our
server list compute environments at the
same time in cloud functions your
language selection is a little bit more
limited we've only got node Python and
go for that right now and you have to
code in a way that's specifically
intended for cloud functions so if
you've got a larger expressed @j s or
django web app that you want to bring
into server lists cloud functions might
not be your choice for that that would
need serious refactoring to work in
cloud functions and the flipside of not
worrying about concurrency is you don't
have access to concurrency you can't say
you know give me a hundred requests that
run at once I can run a hundred threads
you're limited to one request at once
per instance so miles will walk you
through some of the cloud functions
we've got so the first function that we
created was create short link this is
the function that we're gonna call to
make new short links or alternatively
fail if it doesn't work it takes a URL
and a short link as a parameter and it
stores it in the database the next
function that we created
was get short link and that takes a URL
as a parameter and then it it takes a
short link as a parameter and then it
gives you back the URL itself that
you're supposed to go to so let's take a
look at this turtle here and what
they're asking us to do it's telling us
to go to the demo and I always listen to
what turtles tell me to do so here we're
in the cloud console again and this is
the landing page for functions we've got
the create short link function and the
get URL short the get URL function let's
dig into the create URL function and see
what's going on here the first thing
that we'll notice is we got some really
great insight into the usage we can see
the most recent invocation that was the
demo that I just showed you earlier we
could see the usage over the last 30
days and we can see the day that I sent
this service to all my friends to try to
break it before I used it onstage we
also get access to a couple other things
we have the trigger itself right here so
we can click this link and you could see
we get an error because we haven't sent
the right request we can see the source
code as well by clicking on source if we
look at index J s here we can see
there's a couple helper functions that
we've made for interacting with the
database and here you can see the
general way in which we create functions
I'm giving I'm exporting the function
with the name of what my service will be
called and that export is an
asynchronous function this will allow me
to use the await keyword I don't know
how many people here are familiar with
Java Script and async await oh very cool
I think it's like made the language
infinitely better to work with and a
really cool thing with cloud functions
as you can it export async functions
which makes it far simpler to start
doing some asynchronous stuff you get a
request in a response for an HTTP
function and it's more or less the exact
same contract as an Express app if
you're used to using Express so here we
have a couple different things that
we're doing to make sure that we've
gotten a good request and sending proper
warnings when we haven't and then when
we actually make the call to the
database here we can send the right
information if the result was successful
and warned if it wasn't now we also in
the
function's thing here have the ability
of testing the function itself so we can
go ahead and give the long link to
google.com and try to test that function
and see what happens and it gave us back
a warning that we should also include
the short link so let's do that right
now and we'll give it the short link
Google we could test the function and it
successfully returned the short link
which means that the service worked so
if we go back really quickly to get URL
and we can jump right to testing it we
can call get URL with the short link
Google we could test the function and we
can see that we got back the URL that we
created one of the things you will
notice with this service is that we're
not baking in any of the host names so
it's really cool about this is this
service can sit on top of n number of
different URLs in the database could
even transfer around for other services
so that's what to show right now for the
functions if we go back to the slide
deck we're gonna look at the next
technology that we used which was App
Engine which we used for the front end
and Niomi will walk us through a little
bit about App Engine and why you might
want to use that specific product where
as functions was one operation and
you're done you just do one function
return the response to that and done in
App Engine you write a service that can
deal with a variety of paths and can do
a variety of related operations you
still have a lot of the benefits of
functions like the automatic security
patching of libraries the libraries are
still resolved in the cloud but you have
a few more language runtimes available
we have Java Python go PHP and node and
you can bring your own web application
framework or mobile backend application
framework if you want to write in Django
you can write in Django flask you can
write in flask can you tell that I'm a
Python person rather than a node person
mostly and you can have the idiomatic
language
to what you're used to sue write the
code that you're used to using deploying
to any other kind of situation you write
that you send it up to your right you
write that you send the code up to us in
the cloud we resolve the dependencies
for you in a language idiomatic way and
we make your code run and we scale it
automatically and do the server list
thing for you
in all the ways that I described server
list before miles will describe the
front-end that we wrote in App Engine so
we have a couple different routes that
were handling in App Engine with the
Express app that we built the first
route is just slash it's what happens at
the root and for that we serve a form
for a new short link the next route that
we have is a post to slash link this is
the endpoint that we post to to create
new short links that will then proxy
that request to the cloud function that
I was showing earlier finally we have a
post to get short link this is very
similar to just get on the root except
we catch any other words that are there
to be used as a parameter for figuring
out hey what's short link are we asking
for and then we serve the appropriate
redirect for the browser so I think the
turtle is telling us it's time to show
off a demo again so here we're in the
App Engine console and if you were
trying to figure out how to get it if
you click the navigation menu here you
can see that we've pinned it but if you
just were to scroll down on the products
page to compute it's right in there and
you can click on App Engine and then
click on dashboard to get to the page
that I'm on right now we can see the
requests that have come through you know
and take a look at them we can see
services we have one default service
that's deployed right now but you can
deploy multiple services multiple
independent App Engine instances all on
the same project you're not limited to
one we have various versions these are
all the different versions that we've
deployed of this application as you can
see we've made some changes over time
one of the things that I really love
about this is the traffic allocation bit
that you can see here it makes it really
intuitive and straightforward with a
couple clicks to split traffic a couple
across a couple different instances one
time where I find this extremely useful
is hey we've made a small change and
we're not a hundred percent whether or
not this is going to break some people
you can do a new version not
automatically deploy its production and
just read about maybe ten percent or
five percent of traffic to that service
you can even run that service with
special headers in the logger so it's
easier to see exactly what's going on
and progressively roll out that service
over time instead of just transitioning
all the traffic at once you'll be able
to see there's a handful of other things
in the menu here we're not going to dig
too much into those right now but I
would say the cron jobs are also one of
my favorite things and cloud scheduler
is another product you can look into but
let's take a look at the code that we're
using here in our front-end service here
we have you know it's a package.json
it's a idiomatic nodejs app we have a
handful of different dependencies not
many dead dependencies the one main
thing that you definitely need when
you're doing things with App Engine is
the app dot yamo file this runtime line
right here is actually the only thing
that you need to include to get
something deployed and we're saying you
know which runtime we're using these
handlers that you see below here what
are we're using to specify the static
content so during the deployment
everything that's in slash stylesheets
in slash scripts and slash star are
going to be cached by a CDN at the edge
we know that all these assets are static
so by creating these handlers App Engine
smartly knows how to how to cache that
and then we have app dot j/s here which
is the main entry point into our
application we've got a little bit of
song-and-dance here and the code is
available online we'll give you a link
at the end of the presentation but the
two biggest things to check out here are
these two bits right here and this is
idiomatic express for saying hey here
are particularly hit those routes let's
use these particular middlewares and
you'll notice that we have two different
routes that we're doing one being the
index route that's handling both the
case of hitting slash as well as hitting
any of the parameters and then link
which is the endpoint that we're posting
to to create a new link so one of the
things that I wanted to show really
quickly
is how we can quickly update and
redeploy the application so we're in the
front end app now if we go here in the
front end and we take a look at our view
and we have indexed pub here and you can
see that this is where we get that
header for URL shortener and let's just
change that to hello IO
and we're gonna save that we're gonna
see the get status we can see the diff
by the way what we're using right now is
called the cloud shell and we're also
using the cloud editor this is all built
right into Google cloud we're changing
this all live on the stage with a
Chromebook you can do this on the road
with pretty much anything that has a
keyboard and a browser and if you're in
cloud source repositories which is where
I was showing this for it allows you to
push git repositories right to cloud you
can literally click this button right
here edit code and that's gonna open up
this cloud shell environment that you
see me working in so we've now changed
hello IO and we're gonna run g-cloud app
deploy and it's going to say hey you
sure you want to do this I'm pretty sure
I want to do and no such component oh I
know what's going on here we need to
just npm install really quickly thank
you for being patient with me this is
what happens when you try to do things
on stage live how many people have done
live demos before okay hold on keep your
hands up for a second lower your hand if
you've ever had a live demo not blow up
in your face so we're almost done here
we're just about done I'm doing a really
good job of stalling and now we'll
g-cloud app deploy they'll say yes the
reason why that happened is because I'm
doing some fancy thing with symbolic
links I should have learnt the lesson
about symbolic links at some time in the
past but I didn't so let's just go back
I want to show you one more thing in app
engine well that's deploying that I
didn't show you here in the settings
you'll notice when we were on the site
that we're at min
knish not at like an app engine specific
site app engine supports custom domains
so you'll notice here that I've created
a custom domain it gives me all the
rules to set up I just put that into my
DNS settings and now that domain will
always forward to the App Engine
instance App Engine will also provision
all the SSL certificates for you so as
you noticed we were doing everything at
HTTPS and I believe if I just go to HTTP
you can see my muscle memory won't even
let me go to non secure it automatically
upgrades the traffic for you as well
so I really highly suggest just using
that right off the bat so we go back to
the cloud shell it's already I've been
talking long enough that it works and if
we refresh now it says hello IO so not
the most exciting change that we're
doing live but I didn't want to change
too much but you can get a little bit of
an idea now about the end-to-end
workflow of working with App Engine and
you could take any idiomatic framework
that you want to work with if you're
more into happy or into FASTA Phi or
just you know writing something by hand
with net you can deploy anything that's
idiomatic node with App Engine so if we
head back to the deck right now we had
one last service that we haven't talked
about yet which is the one that I'm most
excited about which is cloud run the
product that I only helped build sooner
I made you want to tell us a little bit
more about what cloud run is sure cloud
run anywhere as an app engine you write
with your favorite framework in cloud
run you can include arbitrary software
cloud run is our service container
runtime so with containers these are
these are just your normal docker
containers for people who are familiar
with that you can use any language any
libraries you want any binaries you want
if you have software that comes
prepackaged as a binary and you can use
the whole ecosystem of docker base
images that already exists in places
like docker hub so you can have an
Ubuntu base image or or even a node.js
base image and docker containers have
become the industry standard for
software transmission basically each
docker container
it contains all that's necessary for the
software on it to pretend it's running
in its own computer though it's not
actually that's all operating system
fakery that gives it that impression
it's much faster than provisioning a VM
so the product we have for our container
runtime is cloud run container to
production in seconds while still being
server list without and having to
provision anything or anything like that
it scales up fast and down to zero when
you're not using it and you pay for the
exact usage that you're you're using so
we actually have two versions of cloud
run cloud run fully managed is the one
that we mostly talk about but there's
also cloud run on gke cloud run fully
managed Google is your ops team Google
does all the management of scaling up
and down for you it uses our proprietary
back-end and cloud ronan gke is an
alternative form of cloud run that has
the exact same developer experience you
still use the same commands to deploy it
feels the same to deploy it still scales
up fast and down to zero but it's
actually running on a gke cluster that
you or your company manage so you if you
have an ops team that demands that they
have full control over wherever your
stuff is running or or a platform team
that demands full control they can
provision a cloud run on gke cluster you
you your organization pays for the
cluster and then you have the same
developer experience for cloud run and
it still feels serverless to the
developers in your organization any
cloud run fully managed you pay exactly
per use at the hundred millisecond time
scale so per seat you rent CPU you rent
memory and your rent request handling
and then in cloud run on gke you can do
basically the same thing from the
perspective of a development team within
an organization you can use the gke
usage metering feature
so that the development team can get
billed by the operations team in this
same serverless way so when we're
talking about deploying and building for
cloud run there's a couple different
ways to do it the base is that you have
a docker image and that docker image is
on GC R which is Google Cloud repository
that's the right name right Nayomi
Google container container repository I
knew I was wrong that's why I asked
so with cloud build you can create those
images automatically based on git repos
you can also do it yourself with docker
build locally and push upstream and you
can also do that within your own CI CD
infrastructure as long as the image is
on GC our Google container registry
you'll be able to deploy it with cloud
run and you may have been asking what is
a container registry a container
registry is a place to store container
images publicly or privately it works
via using the docker push and pull
command for GC are you pay only for the
storage so when you push a container you
can kind of think of that container like
a series of tarballs
you're storing that inside of a bucket
you're only getting billed for the on
disk space that you're taking up one of
the great things that we do offer as
well when you push containers through
our container registry is that you get
container vulnerability scanning so we
had mentioned before that for like App
Engine and for cloud functions because
everything from the platform such as
nodejs or Ruby down is managed by Google
if there's new versions of node or new
versions of the operating system or
patches that need to be applied to
system libraries we do that all for you
under the hood and the next time we spin
up your containers they just have those
updates automatically
you still need to manage your own
dependencies within your application but
when you're deploying containers
you've contained everything everything
is in there and you're maintaining that
yourself so you're responsible for
making sure that all that stuff is
secure that's part of the the spectrum
that Naomi was talking about earlier you
have more control but that comes with
more responsibility but we still got
your kernel we still we still got your
kernel and in in cloud run but your
libraries you rely on the vulnerable
a scanner and the vulnerability scanner
will let you know if your images that
you have in GCR have any vulnerabilities
in them I'm personally a big fan of that
technology so when you want to go to
deploy this is the command that you
would run and you start with the
registry and you g-cloud betta run
deploy because the thing is still in
beta image and then the link to the
registry cloud run takes that container
registry image deploys it and gives you
a URL that you can then visit to see
your service in production and similarly
to App Engine you can also set up custom
domains and those custom domains will
have manage SSL for you so your whole
deployment can just be g-cloud betta run
deploy and if any of you have any
experience with cloud build it's fairly
intuitive to set that up to be automated
based on pushes to a git repo or all
sorts of other triggers that can set
this off to automate a continuous
deployment for you
cloud run is based on K native which is
a common API and runtime environment for
serverless containers so one of the
wonderful things about cloud run is if
you obey the contract for what a
container should and shouldn't do you
can port that container to anywhere that
runs k native now you you might have to
like dig yourself access holes to any
other Google cloud services that you use
but if you follow the container contract
it should be reasonably portable between
K native deployments so cloud run is a
kind of K native deployment cloud run on
GK e and K native is actually open
source software so you can take K native
and install it on a kubernetes cluster
of your choice the reference
implementation is based on kubernetes or
go to another k native cloud provider
and take your same container and put it
there so you might have heard about
problems with lock-in and locking into
one Clow
Fahd run is what you might want to
choose if you want to run a multi cloud
deployment or not have to worry about
lock-in you can actually take your
container and leave Google with it and
get a very similar environment not only
the runtime environment but also the
deployment workflow is is both the same
it uses the same API and the same
runtime environment the container
runtime contract that I've mentioned has
a few things in it I'm just gonna give
some highlights this is the key native
container runtime contract the first
thing is you need to make your container
have a stateless service in it so if you
need a database you need to put that out
of your container and connect to it if
you need access to files you need to put
them in some kind of cloud bucket Google
Cloud Storage is one of the
possibilities there but basically
anywhere on the cloud that you can store
your files
I only just a quick question for you
statelessness isn't that something we
need to worry about all the time and
server lists it is something you need to
worry about all the time in service both
functions and App Engine do require
statelessness in their operation the
next thing is whatever your container is
it needs to listen for HTTP requests on
dollar-sign port that's how stuff gets
in and the response is how stuff gets
out if you like a little a little thing
is in cloud run mostly that's the same
port all the time but if you want to be
able to be porting from cloud run to
other cañedo installations you want to
listen on dollar side port because they
might set that to something else and
another thing that you have to worry
about is not using CPU outside of
requests you're only guaranteed to get
access to the CPU while you're answering
requests the system reserves the right
to scale you down at any time when
you're not answering a request there's
like a few other things about like
handling signals and things like that
and that's documented with key native
and with cloud run you can look that up
on our documentation so in our container
anything unix goes
so we decided to just use a few
old-school UNIX programs and write as a
server list bash program for handling
our 404s so we we use the UNIX program
fortune to pipe it to the UNIX program
cows a and serve the results with the
UNIX program netcat and it's n cat
variety high net cat all right let's see
it
so over here we're in the cloud run
dashboard and we have one service called
fortune-telling cow and I'm gonna click
on that to take a peek at it
and it has a lot of revisions and very
similar to the App Engine world you can
you can see all your revisions you can
manipulate them you can even go to the
yamo view and see the kubernetes style
yeah mol that you have that has to do
with the K native API and you can get
all the details there so I'm going to go
over to the cloud shell and show how a
workflow might work here and how our app
works here's our repository here with
our served SH and I'm going to increase
the size of this window briefly and you
can see that the served Sh
sets a port if they if it isn't provided
but we're going to connect to the port
environment variable we traps against to
kill things and then what we do is we
start the program n cat tell it to
listen and keep listening for more
connections even after the first one on
the port dollar sign port see also the
container contract and then whenever it
gets a connection exact the following
things echo HD beginning of an HTTP
response give it a content type header
of plain text and then pipe the result
of fortune two to cow say and so let's
look at what happens when when I run
that to run that what I need to do is I
need to do a docker build and
and I'm going to give it a tag of the of
the image environment variable right dot
love oh I need to be in the right
directory before I do that and I give it
I give it the image environment variable
and I'll as soon as soon as this
finishes I'm going to give I'm going to
show you what's in the image environment
variable it's not complicated it's just
where I'm going to put this thing on on
GCR okay so now I I want to do docker
run - - RM to finish when I'm done - - I
T so it's interactive and gets the
terminal and - P and then I want to map
port 8080 - 8080 and so this is just how
you might run an image and now we can
see over in the cloud shell we can
preview this on port 8080 to see what's
going on here and we have our wonderful
fortune-telling cow kill that window
control C control C out of this business
alright so in our cloud run workflow I
might want to change this let's say I
don't want a turtle to say this I want a
different or I want to don't want a cow
to say this I want a different kind of
of cow which is turtle in terms of cows
a turtle is a kind of cow who knew and I
want to save this file and now I want to
do another docker build that happens
very fast because I'm only changing the
one layer of this docker file that I
that I have here by the way let's take a
brief look at the docker file all this
docker file says it's it's based on
Alpine Linux we want to install the few
programs that we use here's the
installation of N
the installation of fortune we have a
more complicated installation of cows a
because we're installing it from a git
repository copy every file from this
directory into the image build a set of
wholesome fortunes because we don't want
to demo unwholesome fortunes for you set
up and set up our path environment
variable and set the command to be this
served Sh that we that we viewed fun
story it was originally called server
but I only noticed that we wouldn't be
serverless if we call this server Sh
so it's just sir there is no server
involved so now that we've know that
we've built that docker container we can
push it to GC our docker pushed dollar
sign image so that pushes although all
of those layers that we've created one
of them already exists probably the base
image and as soon as we get our prompt
back we can do G cloud beta run deploy
and the name of our service is fortune -
telling - cow and - - image and our
image cool let's deploy that to our
cloud run service and you see it tells
you it tells you what it's doing well
it's deploying I'm actually in charge of
the command line so I'm like proud of
all this interactiveness it health
checks it before it migrates any traffic
to it so if as soon as you send any
request to your thing it crashes it
won't migrate any traffic it will let
you know that there's an error cool it's
deployed and is serving traffic so we
can go and check out this URL
fortune-telling cow oh dear did I
misspell turtle
I'm sorry - F turtle now I need two
docker build and deploy very quickly I
think this is a really great example
though of how quick this workflow is and
for those of you have experience with
GCF vs. app engine it takes a little bit
more time because all of its
infrastructure is all being managed by
us at once but just in the time that it
took me to stall and talk to you all
we're almost done deploying this whole
service upgrading all the traffic and
rerouting it I think it's probably going
to only be about another 10 or the
healthcheck we're routing traffic
assigning traffic to the latest ready
revision and we're done
and we're done and you should be able to
hit refresh on this instance turtle stay
with me turtle I'm sorry we have a
turtle turtle yeah we have a turtle and
and now if we go in and in our in our
micro services based app hit something
that we don't know we can see that we
have a turtle instead of a cow that mile
instead of the cow that miles showed you
before now if we can go back to the
slides so we've gone through a handful
of different service offerings that we
have at Google we primarily focused on
our computer frames which are the ones
in the center so I was cloud functions
App Engine and cloud run which is you
know the new exciting technology that
we've got we also showed some other
technologies that you may not have the
mental model of thinking about is
service selection as cloud sequel which
is being managed by us and can scale to
zero now there's other database
technologies that we have that we
consider server list there's messaging
services such as bub sub DevOps services
such as cloud scheduler that I was
mentioning before which is basically
managed cron so if there's anything that
you ever wanted to do that's based on a
timing it just thinks is so easy to do
we made sure machine learning API is as
well as well as stuff around
and chat but you can build large
services with all of those a really
quick summary though functions do one
thing apps do many things run do
anything and thank you so much I'm Myles
this is Naomi if you take a look at the
next slide you can see mndot knish slash
source is a short link that will take
you to the git repo for the project also
check out developers.google.com/plus
comm slash serverless
you know we're on Twitter and email and
all those things grabbed us afterwards
if you have questions thank you all so
much for sticking around so late
[Applause]
[Music]